NARRATOR:
Tonight on "Shark Tank"...
Things get even more heated
when the men take on the women.
The difference between us
and the girls
is that I actually own
businesses that I can
place orders for.
Are you sick?
Why is it every time
there's a female product
on this show,
you guys go out right away?
No, it's -- that's crap.
NARRATOR: In the tank,
hopeful entrepreneurs
get a once-in-a-lifetime chance
to pitch the sharks
in hopes
of getting an investment
to start, grow,
or save their businesses.
[ laughter ]
No!
The entrepreneurs
must convince a shark
to invest the full amount
they're asking for,
or they'll walk away
with nothing.
This is fraudulent behavior.
Listen, you're just taking
the guy down
and making him feel
like he can't do this.
I'm not finished
taking him down!
NARRATOR: If the sharks hear
a great idea...
What was your profit?
$2.65 million.
You're killing it!
NARRATOR: ...They're ready
to invest using their own money.
And they're willing
to fight each other
for a piece of the action.
I'll take that deal.
Wait. We didn't hear it.
I'm a big guy.
Whoa, whoa!
Do we have a deal?
Wait. You know the histories
of Barb and I.
It's never gonna go
into retail.
How insulting!
Barb, want to go in with me?
O'LEARY:
If 30% is available --
no problem at all, baby.
I'm right there with you.
okay.
It is a guy thing.
I love it.
You need to say yes
now to us.
What the hell is this?!
You're just
in a lousy mood today.
Don't turn your back
in the tank.
NARRATOR:
Who are the sharks?
They're self-made millionaire
and billionaire investors
who are entrepreneurs
themselves.
Kevin O'Leary
is a venture capitalist
who turned a $10,000 loan
into a software business
worth $4.2 billion.
Barbara Corcoran went
from waiting tables in Manhattan
to building the city's
preeminent real-estate empire.
Robert Herjavec, the son
of an immigrant factory worker,
is now a technology mogul
who sold his first internet
companies for over $350 million.
Lori Greiner, the queen of QVC,
holds over 100 patents and
has launched over 300 products,
grossing over a half a billion
dollars in retail sales.
And Mark Cuban,
notorious billionaire
entrepreneur, tech guru,
and the outspoken owner
of the NBA's Dallas Mavericks.
First into the tank
is a dynamic product
designed to help businesses
attract customers.
Hi, sharks.
I'm Scott Adams.
I'm Josh Faherty.
And we're from Sacramento,
California.
We are the inventors
of Velocity Signs.
We are seeking $225,000
in exchange for 15% equity stake
in our business.
One day, I was working
in Los Angeles,
driving to a client meeting,
and it was 110 degrees outside.
I looked over on the corner
and saw a poor guy
waving a sign around,
dripping sweat.
His shirt was wet.
Then he rested
in a shaded area
with his sign facedown.
My first thought was,
"poor guy!
He's gonna die
of heat exhaustion."
My second thought -- "There's
got to be a better way."
That's when we launched
Velocity Signs.
[ laughter ]
Portable, rechargeable,
interchangeable,
self-standing,
and most importantly,
they're made to grab
your attention
with its unique movement.
Sharks,
invest in Velocity Signs.
Help us shake our way into every
business all over the world
and put some velocity
back in the American economy.
Do you guys got, like,
a B.B. gun or something?
It's like we're at the arcade.
Bam, bam.
[ laughter ]
Down goes Kevin.
You're the guy that
looks like something
out of a horror movie.
[ laughing ] Hey!
How substantial are they? Are
they on their feet s-securely?
ADAMS: Good question.
They're 165 pounds, so it's
really hard to tip them over.
So, how much
does this cost?
From $18.99 all the way
up to $2,850.
And how many
have you sold?
We've sold 125
over the last 12 months.
That's all, huh?
125 a year.
So, about $257,000
for over 12 months.
And what -- what's your cost
on a typical --
the Cuban's gonna cost you
about -- about $1,000
cost of goods sold.
To you.
To -- to make it, for me.
Correct.
Oh, okay.
How effective
h-have you found
these are
for your customers?
What do they tell you back?
On average, our clients get
a 15% return on investment.
CUBAN:
What kind of clients?
Our biggest client right now
is little Caesars,
who's got 3,560 locations
worldwide
in 50 different countries.
How many days do I have
to pay a student
to spin signs before I pay
for one of these?
I think the best analogy is
that our machines run nonstop,
so you're getting full use
out of these machines
versus human sign-spinners,
who have to take breaks.
They, uh --
they're hard to manage.
They get tired.
They walk off on the job.
I hate those humans.
The turnover's
extremely high.
GREINER: You know what?
I'll tell you something else.
I always feel sorry
for them.
CORCORAN: Yes.
They have a job, Lori!
ADAMS:
We're creating jobs.
If you -- you can have
that employee
that you run out
waving the sign
move in and do some
more productive work
for your business,
because you're gonna save money
by hiring
that st-- human sign-spinner,
but you're also gonna increase
sales by an average of 15%.
That's $90,000 in new revenue
you can put
to hiring new people.
Well, that's
a decent answer.
So they'll be displaced.
Okay.
They'll be -- they'll be hired
in other positions
that businesses
are gonna be hiring for.
You're a good salesman,
Scott.
Thank you.
What do you want to do
with the money?
What's the world-domination
plan?
We are gonna sell 1,200 units
over the next 12 months.
We're gonna hire
eight sales reps,
and we're gonna hire
four administrative staff.
The other challenge
has been --
I think it's clever, but I
invested in a billboard company
many, many,
many years ago,
and we deal with the --
the electronic signage,
and it was a horrible,
miserable failure.
I'm sorry to hear that.
Now, one thing we found is
that the consumer
gets very old very quickly
with the movement,
and then it needs
to be changed.
Right.
Not a big fan of this business,
so I'm out.
Okay. Robert.
[ laughs ]
GREINER: Cut him off?
No! No!
Gonna turn it off.
[ laughter ]
Smart.
O'LEARY: I love it.
You never told us how much,
on your own forecast,
you think you're going to make
next year.
In very conservative
numbers,
we're gonna
bring in $2.5 million
and bring in $500,000
in sales.
I would like to see a year
or two worth of sales
so that we can see
what the real number is.
My expectation is it'll be
a lot less than you think.
I'm saying I don't know,
so I'm out.
Thank you. Cut it.
[ laughter ]
Thank God!
CUBAN:
I like the business.
The problem is that once you
get one, you don't need two.
I'm out.
Scott, he's out.
Turn him off.
I'm out. Turn me off.
ADAMS: Barbara? Lori?
I was thinking about
the franchises I owned
of real-estate brokers.
What a natural audience
for this.
Absolutely.
They pull it out of the back
of their car,
and they put it
for an open-house sign...
Oh, wow. Absolutely.
...That nobody even wants
to ever go to anymore,
'cause they're tired of seeing
the signs.
And, by the way, why does she
look so much prettier than me?
I'm really pissed over that.
[ laughter ]
and -- and -- but here's
the problem
with even
the real-estate franchisees
or the individual brokers
or agents.
165 pounds out of the trunk
of their car to move it.
So even that perfect
application is filled with --
we didn't tell you
about a new product
we've been working on,
as well.
It stakes in the ground
for real-estate agents.
And then it wiggles.
Smaller battery used
for a short --
because open houses
are all day long.
Why didn't you say it?
Why didn't you tell us about it?
That's a better product.
But you don't have it yet,
so I wish I could see
that product.
Mm-hmm.
If that were the case,
I'd be in.
But I'm sorry.
I'm out.
But would you --
don't turn me off.
Get rid of Lori.
I'm really annoyed
that she's looking
so good up there.
Turn her off!
You don't -- you don't have
to turn Barbara off.
FAHERTY: Sorry, Barbara.
Just throw a bucket of water
on her. She'll melt.
GREINER: Don't turn Lori off!
She's the only one left!
ADAMS: Lori.
[ laughter ]
first of all, I like --
you sell a ton of these
on QVC?
[ laughs ]
No.
CORCORAN: No way, Jose.
But I sell a lot
of other places than QVC.
I think that this is
an extremely smart new way
to draw attention to
brick-and-mortar retail stores
that are on the street
that are hurting right now,
and I think retailers
are going to really love this.
I also like that you'll be
helping these smaller businesses
keep their jobs
and keep their stores.
So I'll offer you $225,000
for 30% of your business.
And, hopefully, together,
we can get this really big and
really out there everywhere,
'cause every franchise
needs this.
I -- we definitely see a value
in your support
and your experience.
O'LEARY:
I'll tell you what.
If you take that deal,
and Lori will have me,
I'll come in on it.
I like it at that valuation.
I'll come in if you want.
I'll come in as a third.
What just happened?!
What just happened?
NARRATOR:
Four sharks were out,
but after Lori
expresses interest,
Kevin and Mark
want a piece of the action.
What just happened?!
What just happened?
ADAMS: So, would that be
10% for Mark,
10% for you,
and 10% for Lori?
Yeah. We'd do that deal,
if Lori says yes.
CUBAN: Yeah.
Are you okay
with that, Lori?
Okay.
So, I made the offer.
O'LEARY: I could sell
a lot of these.
I said $225,000
at 30%, and --
or better yet,
Robert, Kevin, and I
could go in together
if she doesn't like it.
I'm good with that.
And --
oh, yeah?
then I'll go in with Lori.
Wait!
Who believed in you?
No problem.
ADAMS: That's
a good point, Lori.
And who were all the lovely,
little sharks that said,
"I don't believe in you,"
and they dropped out?
O'LEARY: You know what?
I changed my mind.
Instead,
because they're that way --
nobody said that!
I -- Barb, want to go in
with me?
If 30% is available --
no problem at all, baby.
I'm right there with you.
Okay, guys, Barbara and I,
we're going in together,
$225,000 at 25%?
O'LEARY: Here's our deal.
You get three sharks for 30% --
10% each.
We have so many businesses
we can apply this to,
so many contacts
we can phone for you.
Oh, please.
We will set you on fire.
You guys know
whose history --
you know the histories
of Barb and I.
This is not a QVC product!
You know what we've done.
Three is always better than two.
Any math will tell you that.
No, and the only reason
they jumped back in
is because I said what I said
about believing in you...
absolutely.
...And bringing back retailers
and life in America.
What's your offer, Lori?
What's your offer?!
So Barb and I are
at $225,000 for 25%.
Both of us are offering $2--
for 25%.
Three sharks versus two.
We can make a lot of calls.
Are you guys willing
to come down to 25%?
Oh, forget them!
I don't think so.
We add so much extra value.
CUBAN: Well, here -- here's the
other thing I'll throw in.
The difference between us
and the girls
is that I actually own
businesses that I can
place orders for.
Are you sick?
What business do you own?
We own a lot of businesses!
I can place orders.
How do you know
what Barb and I own?
I can place orders.
CORCORAN:
I'm in real estate,
and let me tell you what
I'll throw into the deal.
that's right.
I'm the most influential
real-estate broker
in the country,
the most visible,
the most influential.
I'll be your front man
and make sure
every real-estate broker
in America considers
buying these signs.
I'll get it in front of them.
Scott, you know what Barbara
will do for you?
O'LEARY: Scott,
she works for me!
She'll sell you your mansion
once we make a lot of money.
But you need to say yes
now to us.
GREINER: Ugh.
I really am not comfortable
with you debating this,
because it's so much better
an offer from --
I'm -- I'm gonna order
at least five of them.
Five of them?! What a joke.
Five of them?!
That's just me ordering five
just right off the top.
And I'm gonna sell
probably 50,000 of them
within 6 months.
well, that's -- I'll look at it
for naked pizza.
I'll definitely buy it
for the mavs.
'cause what'll happen is if I
put it in front of the arena
with a dirk head up there,
it's gonna become a landmark.
People are gonna come
and take their pictures with it
and post it everywhere.
GREINER:
I have relationships
with some of the major retailers
in our country,
and some of them
have 3,500 stores, so...
CORCORAN: And Mark is talking
about five signs.
Who are the --
who are those retailers?
Walmart. Bed Bath & Beyond.
Walgreens.
We all work
with the same retailers.
O'LEARY: Come on!
Mine are bigger,
and mine have done more.
You don't think they return
our calls? Are you kidding?
What do you want to do?
Now's the time to decide.
What are you gonna do,
Scott?
Absolutely.
Well, so, we see a value in all
five of you, just so you know.
We appreciate it.
Um, we definitely see a value
in -- in mass quantity
and having three sharks
versus two sharks.
Guys, are you willing
to come down to 25%?
Can't do it.
No.
Are you sure?
Absolutely.
Yep.
We bring so much value.
We don't go at a discount.
Barb, how do you feel
about that?
There are three of us.
We need a -- we need a
bigger number.
If you want to know,
if you ask one more time,
I'm gonna go out.
That's right.
That is so insulting.
Okay.
Uh, we appreciate it.
We think there's more value
en masse,
so we're gonna go ahead and go
with Mark, Kevin, and Robert.
Yes, sir!
All right!
GREINER: That was horrible.
How insulting!
That was horrible.
[ indistinct conversations ]
look at that. look at us.
what kills me is...
I'm excited.
...None of the three of you
even wanted this.
ADAMS: Looking forward
to working with you.
I said I wanted it.
HERJAVEC: Kevin,
this is an extra-large.
Then all of a sudden,
you all wanted it.
This must be yours.
Lori, I can't thank you enough.
We really appreciate it.
Without you, this wouldn't
have happened.
I wanted to work with you.
I really did.
I just saw a value in working
with three versus two.
It wasn't a male
versus female.
It definitely was!
It is a guy thing.
I love it.
Man it up!
You know, I'm not gonna let
any woman in America
ever buy a sign
from them.
yeah.
That's right. Women --
I'm gonna start a campaign.
How insulting!
NARRATOR: Next into the tank
is a re-imagined
favorite snack food.
Hello, sharks.
My name is Sanjiv Patel
from Dallas, Texas,
and my product is
Lord Nut Levington Peanuts.
I'm here today
seeking $500,000
in exchange for 30%
of my company.
So, a bit
about this handsome chap.
Who is Lord nut levington?
Urban legend has it that
Lord nut hails from blighty,
an unsavory land far, far away
across the great pond,
known for its extreme blandness
and lack of flavor.
When he could stand it
no longer,
Lord nut decided upon
a self-imposed exile
and set out for the exciting,
new world in search of flavor.
Later, Lord nut found
his true calling in life --
to fight bland where it hides
and bring freedom of flavor
to the masses.
But before I go on any further,
please take a moment,
tickle your taste buds,
and try some
of our highly seasoned peanuts.
HERJAVEC:
[ chuckles ]
hi, Robert.
if you'd just grab
one of those trays
there...
Oh, thank you, Sanjiv.
...That would be great --
you're welcome.
Yeah.
Here, Lori.
Just grab...
Okay. Wow.
Thank you for that.
You're welcome.
These have a kick to them,
Sanjiv.
Yes, thank you.
Which one did you try?
I tried the El --
cheddarales.
Yeah.
[ chuckles ]
Wow. Ah! Spicy!
O'LEARY: Can I ask you
just a basic question?
Sure.
$500,000 for 30%
imputes a value
of close to $1 1/2 million,
or just over, actually.
yes.
So you must have
some great sales
and distribution, right?
We have some sales, yes.
I launched the brand
in April of 2011.
As of the end of last month,
we've made $700,000
in sales...
Wow.
...Which is the equivalent
of 300,000 cans of peanuts.
What were your sales
last year, Sanjiv?
So, as of the last 12 months,
it's $300,000.
We had some -- it should --
it's flat.
Well, when we started
this company,
we had a couple of big-box
retailers, the discount stores,
that just bought a ton
of product, right?
Okay.
So, you know, it -- it skews
the figures earlier higher.
Now you're normalizing sales
at how much a year?
We're gonna end this year
at about $350,000.
That's where I'm shooting for,
gross sales.
Okay. How much you gonna make
on the $350,000?
We won't make money
this year.
So, why would you be worth
$1 1/2 million?
Because, with -- with
half a million dollars
from the sharks, right,
so...
Yeah, but -- but hang on.
Hang on.
You have a commodity
in peanuts.
I can buy peanuts.
I can flavor peanuts.
I can dry-roast peanuts.
PATEL: That's the piece
you're buying into.
The only thing of value here
is the brand!
Um, well --
I'm never heard of Mr.
"pardon my flavor" nut bar.
Lord levington.
What's his name?
GREINER: Levington.
Lord nut.
I don't know who this guy is,
and the rest of America
doesn't, either.
But we're gonna get there.
Really?
And we're on our way. Yes.
CUBAN: So, what are you
doing to get there?
So, why do you say
that you're on your way?
Currently, we're in
about 600 stores across the U.S.
What kind of stores?
Mainly down
the middle of America.
We're in Wegmans
in the Northeast.
Great company.
We just got into --
well, earlier this year --
into h-e-b in south Texas.
And have they reordered?
Yes. Yes. Yes. Yes.
How much have you invested?
Get ready. $1.1 million.
GREINER: Wow.
Wow!
HERJAVEC: Where did you
get the $1.1 million,
if you can legally
tell me?
So -- [ laughs ]
I can legally tell you.
[ chuckles ]
I came over to the U.S.,
did my M.B.A. at Babson College
in Boston,
known for entrepreneurship.
it's a great school.
When I graduated, I joined
what was then a fledgling
pita chip company,
Stacy's pita chip company,
and I was in charge
of the money.
That's
a very strong brand.
When I -- it is now.
When I joined, we were
about $2 million in sales.
In that journey,
you must remember the days
when you were trying to
get permanent shelf space
for that brand.
Yes.
It's so prohibitive in a
commodity like peanuts or snacks
to get space and keep it,
that you have to have scale
to remain profitable.
You are going to have
to replace
some linear footage
in major retailers...
Yes.
...Against a guy
that has 80% of the market.
In fact, in our industry,
it is very common
that entrepreneurs,
people like me, create brands.
It is the role
of the multinationals,
the larger companies,
to then scale those brands.
That's why we have a thriving
food entrepreneurial industry...
Well said.
...That creates products --
but you have to survive
until you have a --
Sanjiv,
that's a great answer.
I'm right here.
Where am I going?
I'm alive. I'm surviving.
Yeah, but can you give me
an operator in the peanut space
in the last 10 years
that has survived
the slaughter fest
from the big guys?
Why does it have
to be in peanuts? Any
small-food business.
What the hell is this?!
Any small-food business.
PATEL: Just because it
hasn't happened,
do you lose faith in
everything happening
from here forward?
Yes, I lose faith!
He loses faith
in everything.
You're a financial guy.
You know what?
Of course
I'm a financial guy!
Doesn't it say --
doesn't it say past results
are no reflection
of future performance?
Isn't that right?
I also say
don't be an idiot
and invest
where you can't win.
How about
my pork barrel bbq guys?
Yes.
They were
at $500,000 in sales.
It took them a year and a half
to get there,
and then it caught fire,
and now they're over $2 million
in sales.
Yeah.
And you know why?
Every doomsdayer
that said to them
they wouldn't do it,
they ignored,
like this character
over here.
You're doing it
in barbecue sauce.
GREINER:
And you know what?
It's just the same
as peanuts?
Listen, you're just taking
the guy down
and making him feel
like he can't do this.
I'm not finished
taking him down!
I can't follow you down
this path to hell,
and I won't do it.
I'm out.
I respect that. Thank you.
Sanjiv,
I have a question.
Yes.
You didn't, uh,
mention earlier
how you developed
all these flavors.
Yeah.
Did you cook them up
yourself?
Yeah, I'm not a cook.
I'm not a chef.
I can't mix things up and say,
"here's a great recipe."
you know, that's the missing
piece for me --
passion for the product.
I almost feel like you're
a left-brain --
how could you not hear
the passion for the product?
he's got it all over.
CORCORAN: He's got cute names,
but I haven't heard
any love of your peanuts
from you at all.
Forgive me, but every
food business I've
gotten involved in...
Well --
...that was front and center,
and I'm not getting it.
I'm out.
So...Here's my feeling.
I couldn't try
your peanuts,
because peanuts
don't agree with me.
oh.
Because I can't even eat
your product
or even try it,
I'm out.
I understand. Thank you.
So, Sanjiv, I love --
unlike Kevin, I really like
disruptive technologies.
So I have no problem
with the market
that you're going into.
Mm.
But I didn't hear
the plan.
I didn't hear anything
that makes me want
to spend
half a million dollars
to help you build the brand
going forward.
I-I got to be out.
CUBAN:
Sanjiv, here's my problem.
What you haven't talked to
is sales velocity, right?
Yes.
Here's your chance right now
to tell me
here's why they're flying off
the shelves,
or here's why they will,
because that's the missing
piece, so tell me.
We're bringing
a different shade of product
into this category
with a fun, exciting brand
that people
feel passionate about.
There is no water-cooler
talk happening about
those other products.
There's no water-cooler
talk talking about
Lord nut levington.
Well, people get
quite -- people are excited
when they try our product.
That's -- see, now you went
from giving data
to talk
and giving stories.
I don't see it
as blowing out the doors,
and I don't think this is enough
capital to correct mistakes.
Your problem is sales not flying
off the shelf. I'm out.
Okay. I respect that.
Thank you.
Are we done?
Is that everyone?
That's everyone.
We're done big-time.
[ laughs ]
It's lovely to meet you.
Good luck, Sanjiv.
Thank you. Bye.
Great guy.
Lovely man.
PATEL: Great opportunity.
Loved being here.
Now I'm gonna go out
there and fight bland
and sell some peanuts.
That's what I count on.
I'm gonna give the guy
a ton of credit,
because he came in
and kicked Kevin's butt.
yeah!
He -- he did, and he does have
a passion and drive.
I don't know
about that, Mark.
If I was wrong, Mark,
he would be covered in offers.
And look. Oh, oh, oh!
He didn't get any offers!
CUBAN: But no, he --
you're just in a lousy mood
today. it's terrible.
NARRATOR: Next into the tank
is an entrepreneur
from Louisville, Kentucky,
with a product he believes
is like a vacation
for your feet.
[ chuckles ]
Hi. My name is Pat Yates.
My company is Happy Feet,
and I'm seeking $375,000
for 15% equity in my company.
Happy feet are not
your grandma's slippers.
They're playful, fun,
and so comfortable, they're
like walking on pillows.
They come in almost every color
imaginable,
including our top-selling
leopard and zebra print,
as well as the red, black, and
white collegiate-licensed design
of my beloved
Louisville cardinals.
Ha!
[ laughter ]
Also, don't forget about
our cool animal styles --
lion, tiger, giraffe, and
the ever-tough shark slippers.
Happy feet are great
for people of all ages.
Now, sales are great,
but we need your help
to expand
in our international markets
as well as to take it
into retail.
Now, which of you sharks
is ready to take the walk
with Happy Feet?
And I know you won't want
to take them off.
Awesome. Yeah.
Bring them on.
GREINER: Good.
All right, so, we're gonna do it
a little different.
I know
where that pair is going.
Mark, you're an athlete,
a basketball guy.
Yeah, I know.
Basketball guy,
basketball guy.
Go, hoosiers, baby.
There you go. All right.
Go, hoosiers.
GREINER: [ laughs ]
oh, come on, Mark.
Go, hoosiers.
The hoosiers?
Barbara, you got the leopard.
Grr. There you go.
Got to catch it. Oh, see?
HERJAVEC: She's an animal.
Doggone!
Give me another shot.
I -- but I threw it short,
though.
[ sighs ] Too bad.
For the shark
of all sharks, Mr. O'Leary.
O'LEARY: Hey! Love it.
See, he can't catch,
either!
All right, Lori.
You're gonna get the neon zebra.
For you, Robert -- penguin.
A penguin?!
What the hell is that?!
I don't know! We came up
with an animal!
It's just a cute animal!
What am I?!
What am I,
the friggin' fluffy shark?!
I think about Canada,
I think of penguin.
What's wrong with that?
Give me the lion.
I don't want the penguin!
You want the lion? Okay.
Hold on. Go ahead. Give it back.
All right.
We'll get you the lion.
I think you'd look good
in a penguin, Robert.
There we go.
Oh, my gosh.
These are my new shoes!
All right!
YATES: There we go.
These are amazing.
They're like moon boots.
Absolutely.
Exactly.
CUBAN: I used to have
a pair of moon boots.
Wow.
HERJAVEC:
They're so comfortable!
Wow.
They really are.
See? Look at that.
Wow.
Look how good he looks
in those sharks.
HERJAVEC: Wow. Why are these
so comfortable, pat?
Well, it is -- it's that 1-inch
foam rubber bottom.
It's a dense foam rubber
that we put in them.
Just, the whole thing,
when you step down on it,
it's like walking
on pillows.
So, pat, $375,000 for 15%.
Your sales must be amazing!
We've done $6.5 million
in the last 3 years...
You got to be kidding.
...Between internet
and wholesale -- yes.
HERJAVEC: What are your sales
last year?
GREINER: What stores --
what stores are you in?
What are your sales
last year?
Sales last year
were $2.65 million.
And the year before?
Uh, $2.4 million.
So, pat,
out of the $2.6 million,
what percentage is online?
It's -- actually,
of that $2.6 million,
it was probably
about $2.2 million,
which is
the highest margin portion.
You're selling that
much stuff online? Wow.
Wow.
And what does it
cost you to make?
The sneaker-slipper styles
cost about $5.50.
We sell them $24.99 to $29.99,
which is about a 400% markup
right there.
That's a great margin.
Pat, that $2.6 million
you sold last year --
what was your profit
on that?
About $600,000.
So, where are you spending
all your money?
Um...
Because with that big
of margins,
you should be making
more than $600,000.
We do a ton of free shipping
at our busiest time,
which is holiday, which knocks
that margin down significantly.
But the problem was, the margin
and the seasonality
of the business
being a little bit seasonal
in the winter,
it's sort of shot down
some of those profits,
and I didn't have --
why haven't you focused
on getting
into major retail stores?
Well, there are
several reasons.
Okay.
Number one --
the size of the product.
They were afraid
it was too big.
Exactly.
O'LEARY: It takes up 2 1/2 times
the linear square feet
that an ordinary shoe
would take.
It is.
It's never gonna go
into retail.
O'LEARY: I have
a different problem with it.
You got to help me with this,
'cause this is the thing
that's bugging me the most.
There's nothing proprietary
about this stuff.
I'm very worried
that someone else
is gonna come in here
and drop the prices by 30%.
Yeah.
...Because I've never seen
margins like this in slippers.
Like, this is incredible.
Do you have competitors
that are doing the same thing?
We -- we don't.
Anybody that you see
selling these online
are buying from us.
GREINER: How are people
knowing you're there?
This is the thing
I want to understand,
'cause you have
an amazing online business.
We also did a license with a
girl who was on a reality show
that really built a lot
of social following behind it
that we still have, as well.
who?
Snooki.
We utilized her Twitter account
as well as her social,
to be able to grow it.
who is it?
was it Snooki?
Another -- yeah.
[ chuckles ]
and we ended up getting
onto a business
where we could find
those mid-level social stars
that would help get our name
out there and grow it.
Are you saying
Snooki's mid-level?
She was
when we found her.
[ laughter ]
She won't like
that I said that.
But she's fantastic.
Wow. Wow.
And how much are you having
to pay for those folks?
Uh, it's about 12%.
Ah, therein lies --
that's where
the money's going.
That's where the money --
it's not --
it's not all of it
going to that,
though, Mark.
no, but --
but it's actually fed
what we're growing.
So we've really tried to create
our own marketing.
That's really what I'm about.
So, proprietary's important,
but when you have
someone like me
that's gonna go out and try
to market and work hard --
pat, you're killing it!
Well -- right!
CORCORAN:
Pat, time out for a moment.
There's something that's
really disturbing me.
You know, it feels to me
as though you may have peaked
or are maybe
even on the way down.
But it feels to me you're not
going to get bigger. I'm out.
I mean --
pat, look, you --
great business, right?
I'm an intense entrepreneur,
Robert.
Oh, my friend,
I get that from you.
This is
a real business.
Right.
You've done
a fantastic job.
Pat, I-I don't see
where I add value.
I like to add value.
I'm a good operator,
just like you are.
I like to run things.
I like to add value to people.
I don't like to just write
a check to something.
Let me ask you
one other question,
one thing
I was gonna talk about.
Look, I-I don't want you
to waste all your time with me.
You're doing a great job.
I don't want to write a check,
and that's it. I'm out.
Thank you, Robert.
I understand.
O'LEARY: How many pair
are you gonna sell this year?
75,000 to 100,000.
The challenge is,
15% is nothing, nothing to me.
Right.
It just --
it's not exciting.
I understand.
But I understand partnering
with a shark
isn't a bad thing
for this online business,
because together, we could
probably sell a ton more.
I'm gonna make you
an offer.
I'll give you $375,000,
and I want a $3 royalty
on every pair sold
until I get
my $375,000 back.
[ laughter ]
Chimed right in.
Let's see him
make an offer.
He likes to make
a lot of noise
but doesn't often make
an offer.
no, it just --
I want a 5% -- as I like to say,
"wet my beak" -- equity,
just so we can say
we're partners.
And I'll -- after I recoup
my capital, I'll drop down
to $1.50.
That's three times more
than Snooki got!
Look. I love Snooki,
but you got Mr. Wonderful here.
That's a whole
different ballgame.
GREINER: I like it.
I might offer to go in with
Kevin, if he would have me...
If you can convince me,
because I like to go bigger.
I think it would be great
if you could expand into retail.
So, Lori, I just want
to confirm something.
Okay.
You want to go 50/50
on the deal.
Yes.
One modification
we have to make --
I believe that decimals
are bad karma,
so you have to go up to 6%
on the "wet your beak" equity.
[ laughs ]
So it's 3% each, okay?
We give him $375,000.
We split that.
And your one covenant is
that he attempt retail again.
Yes.
I am prepared to go on there
and Snooki it out.
Snooki it out, huh?
Well, who needs Snooki
when you got pookie?
I think Mark should jump
all over this.
Mark, I-I hope
that you see the passion.
I mean, I've heard you talk
about entrepreneurs.
And you sold garbage bags,
right?
Door to door.
I have -- I have a story,
if you'd give me two minutes.
Sure.
My mom passed away
a year and a half ago
really kind of unexpectedly,
and this was
her favorite story of me.
I had a guy, a kid --
when I was playing basketball
in the backyard with a kid,
his dad was throwing
some calendars out.
I looked at them.
They were last year's calendars.
I took those, and I literally
walked my way home
and sold every one
of those calendars.
The retail
does have challenges,
but I'm gonna get up
every day
to make sure this business
continues to grow.
You -- you do not
have to sell me.
You are the real deal,
right?
I appreciate that.
You've got a great business,
but it's not a fit for me.
I'm out.
I appreciate that, Mark.
You're welcome.
Thank you.
Well!
GREINER: [ laughs ]
pat, three sharks
are out now.
All roads lead back.
You know,
I-I-I really appreciate that.
Um, I don't think it's
the right situation for me.
I really appreciate
the offer, but...
Hallelujah.
The only thing that I could do
is maybe counter back.
I really want you all --
what is your counter?
NARRATOR:
Three sharks are out.
Pat has an offer
from Kevin and Lori --
$375,000 for a 6% stake,
plus a $3 royalty
which drops to $1.50
after the investment
is repaid,
which pat feels
is too steep.
What is your counter?
I would be willing to do
$375,000 for 20%,
to go into that and -- and have
you all help me grow it.
I think that that is
a-a reasonable number.
I --
you understand the value
of two sharks?
Do you have any idea
what's going to happen
to your sales?
I -- 100%. I just don't like
the royalty structure.
I would love to find a
percentage that you all
make sense.
Okay, so you don't like
my royalty deal.
If you want me to go
straight equity,
that's gonna take me a lot
longer to get my money back,
so I've got to increase
the amount I'm going to get.
Here's the new offer --
and Lori may come in with me,
as she did
on the royalty deal --
$375,000 for 30%.
I'll do that.
I'm in with you.
I'll give you $375,000
for 30%.
Wow.
O'LEARY: Robert's jumped
back into this.
He was out for a while,
but now he's offering you...
Pat's selling me!
...$375,000 for 30%,
which was the exact same offer
that Lori and I gave you.
The difference is you get
two sharks instead of one.
Right.
I think that if either one
of you would do 25%,
that's gonna be my top end.
Why would you take that, though?
Why would you do that?
How much cash do you guys have
in the bank right now?
Well, I mean,
we have $200,000.
25%, $375,000.
O'LEARY: 25%?
But I would like them
to be able to help
with -- with where
we're headed.
I don't know
that I can --
pat, I'll take
that deal.
Wait. We didn't hear it.
I'm a big guy.
Whoa, whoa! Wait.
$375,000, 25%.
Do we have a deal?
Wait.
Done.
Done! I like you, pat!
CORCORAN: Wow. Bam.
Wham, bam,
thank you, Ma'am.
Great job!
Well, we were talking.
We shouldn't have been talking.
There you have it.
CORCORAN: Wow!
That was
a great presentation.
Thank you.
Appreciate it, guys.
Robert,
that was a great move!
CORCORAN: Wow, Robert.
He sees us talking.
You deserve to lose it.
Don't turn your back
in the tank.
Good job, Robert.
Why, thank you, Mark.
You can learn a thing or two
from me.
I did on that one.
YATES:
It was incredible, I mean,
especially
to pull Robert back in
after he had already gone
through it and said he was out.
He saw my passion.
He saw my interest.
And he's really a guy
that I had at the top of my list
of who I wanted,
so I'm extremely excited.
NARRATOR: Last season,
Byron young pitched the sharks
his multifunctional
beanbag chair.
There's a bed inside!
And he struck a deal
with Lori Greiner.
It's 58%, $200,000.
Take it or leave it.
I came here to make a deal.
Let's do it.
Let's see how Byron
and cordaroy's is doing now.
YOUNG: I never expected
to go on "Shark Tank"
and give up 58%
of my business.
But since partnering with Lori,
she has taken me to levels
that I never even dreamed of.
The orders came pouring in.
In less than 8 months, we've
done over $3 million in sales.
Those aren't projections.
Those are real numbers.
This might just be the ultimate
gift this holiday season.
We recently debuted
cordaroy's on QVC,
and sales went
through the roof.
We did
about $25,000 per minute,
and we oversold our inventory
by 50%.
They slapped us
with a big "sold out" sign,
and it was the best night
of my life.
Hi, Byron!
Hey, Lori!
Working with Lori Greiner
has been amazing.
It seems like
she never stops working,
yet she always answers
the phone.
She's the perfect
business partner.
I have great news
for you today.
We just got another order
for half a million dollars!
Holy cow!
yeah!
Roll up your sleeves,
because you're gonna be
really busy.
I had
a pretty successful business
prior to going on "Shark Tank,"
so I just wasn't sure
if it was the right thing
for me.
But it was the best business
decision I have ever made.
[ duck quacks ]
BICKLEY: Hey, y'all!
I'm Erin bickley, and this is
my friend Jenny Greer,
and we're two sassy Southern
moms living in Macon, Georgia.
There's barely any left
for you.
Hey, don't hog it!
GREER: Don't let
the Southern accent fool you.
When it comes to business,
we're as tough as the peach pit.
My pride and joy.
Erin and I each have three kids,
and we noticed
that our reflections
ain't what they used to be.
It's a Georgia peach...
But it rotted.
[ laughs ]
GREER:
So we searched everywhere
for a solution
to this common problem.
It was nowhere to be found,
so we decided we'd just make it.
BICKLEY: We are on the cusp
of something great,
but the industry we're in
requires so much capital
and so much expertise
to even get to the doors,
much less get them open.
If we don't get a deal from the
sharks, we will be heartbroken.
We've put a lot of blood, sweat,
and tears into this business.
So it's very important to us
that we succeed
and show everyone
that you can have your cake
and eat it, too.
Especially when you're wearing
our product.
Hello, sharks.
I'm Jenny Greer.
And I'm Erin bickley,
and we're from Macon, Georgia.
And we are the head honchos
of Hold Your Haunches.
We are here
asking for $75,000
for a 20% equity stake
in our company.
Hold your haunches is
a fashion trouser
with a fully integrated
shapewear liner.
Our totally unique, chic,
and one-of-a-kind product
offers smoothing
and slimming support
for women of all ages
and stages,
and can be worn
from carpool to cocktails.
A while back,
we were on a walk,
and Jenny was bemoaning
the fact
that despite all efforts
diet- and exercise-wise,
she was unable
to keep her behind
from sagging
below her underpant line...
Ugh!
...Creating what we refer
to as the two-butt effect.
So I said to Erin,
"there has got to be a legging
with a shaper built in!"
to which I replied,
"I can assure you there is not.
I've been in search of this
exact product for over a year."
since we were unable
to find our dream pant
anywhere on this Earth,
we created it.
We married
a chic, modern trouser
to a super-duper
shaping liner,
and Hold Your Haunches
was born.
I'm in the legging,
and Jenny's in the bootcut.
But Hold Your Haunches
is not just about butts.
We shape from muffin top
to belly flop,
saggy cheeks
and saddlebags.
So, sharks, who's ready
to get in our pants?
I-In the picture, is that
the same woman before and after?
It's not me, but --
CORCORAN: Who is it?
It's not you?
Guess who --
guess who that leaves.
Is that you?
Yes!
Is that a real picture?
And that was you before,
and that's you after?
Yes. Yes.
Did you lose weight after?
No, that is
like 5 minutes apart.
No!
And now that I've had
to admit that on TV --
oh, wow. These are strong.
CORCORAN: Wow! Heavy!
I don't think
I have ever felt
a shaper
that is this intense.
And if you'd like --
shaper on steroids.
CORCORAN: Wow.
Wow, that could hold
a lot of heinie in it.
GREINER: This is a shaper
on steroids. Wow.
CUBAN: Holy smokes.
This is
pretty awesome, Barb.
Wow. It must weigh 5 pounds,
these pants.
Barbara, you wear those,
you'll -- you'll have
a blood clot.
I'm wearing them.
[ laughter ]
I'm just disgusted you don't
make a version for men.
BICKLEY: We're going to!
Mark, you could squeeze
in these.
I have a question regarding
the -- the -- the promise
of this nature.
So, let me ask it
to you this way.
Women of certain age that have
a rubenesque figure...
"rubenesque" -- we haven't
heard that in a long time.
Voluptuous.
...And they elect to use
the Hold Your Haunches
lean mean strategy --
this is where I'm
really concerned.
Let's say they meet a single man
that's attracted to the --
okay.
enough, Kevin!
Wait, wait, wait!
Hear me out!
Don't go there.
Let me go there!
Let me go there, because I think
we have to disclose this.
Do not go there.
Let's say they actually go
on that third date,
and then...it's time.
Oh, Kevin.
Now we're facing the truth.
Horrible.
This is a form
of false advertising,
and there should be
litigation!
What about bras, makeup?
HERJAVEC:
Here's the problem.
Who's gonna wear this?
It's gonna be so hot.
It's such
a heavy material.
That's not true.
GREER: It's really not.
BICKLEY: It's not.
It's breathable.
Except for right now.
There's no cotton in it.
It's --
really?
Yes, it's --
you know, honestly,
I-I just have to inform
my fellow male sharks --
'cause I think Barb knows --
women like shapers.
They do.
Every woman wants to look
10 pounds thinner.
If they have muffin-top,
if they have thighs
that they don't like --
whatever it is.
Guys, let me -- let me
simplify things here. Look.
I understand completely
that every tush needs a push.
[ laughs ]
Oh, good one!
That was very good, yeah.
But --
but you're out?
it's not --
but it's not really
my core competency,
so I'm out.
Well, give those
to your wife,
and we'll come do a trunk show
at your house.
that's right.
Erin, I can't see somebody
using it,
'cause it seems
so heavy to me,
which goes to show
I know nothing.
I'm out.
Why is it every time
there's a female product
on this show,
you guys go out right away?
GREINER:
That's right.
We've invested
in many male products.
We give it a chance.
Name one male product.
You say,
"I don't know it enough."
name one male product.
absolutely right.
Scrub daddy.
Go ahead.
That's not a male product!
No, it's -- that's crap.
You're not saying
women need shapers.
You're saying,
"oh, you know what?"
"I don't know anything.
I'm out."
"I don't want to touch that
with a 10-foot pole."
that's what men do -- "I don't
know anything. I'm out."
right.
O'LEARY:
No, I didn't say that.
I know a lot about this.
Okay.
And I'm extremely concerned,
because I think that this
is fraudulent behavior.
I'm all about compliance
and transparency,
and we don't have
any of that.
Wait, wait, wait.
For all the world
to hear...
Yeah.
...If you met a woman
who you thought was dynamite,
and later,
she took those off,
are you telling me
you wouldn't like her?
You know what I'd do?
I'd litigate.
Oh, my God!
[ laughter ]
I can't be a part of this fraud
and false advertising.
Oh, my God.
I'm out.
There's two things
we don't know,
even though they went out
before they ever even heard.
heard.
What do you make it for,
and what do you sell it for?
$18 a pair
to make in Asia.
But door-to-door, $30.
Uh, wholesale for $69
and retail for $139.
Wow.
Now, obviously,
part of this...
Good margins.
...Is also because
we've committed
to smaller quantities.
smaller amount.
What was your profit
on your business last year?
We profited about $50,000
that we put all back
into the business.
That's great.
So that's 30%.
Can you tell us
about the sales so far?
We have sold a total
of $280,000 worth.
And in what period of time?
We sold our first pair online
in November of 2010.
And how -- what were your sales
in only the last 12 months?
$165,000.
I would like to make
an offer with Barb
just so that, down the road,
we could show our male sharks...
Absolutely.
...How they missed out
on something
that could be one of the biggest
sellers of this season.
I know I will get this
on QVC,
and I know the women,
our customers,
would appreciate it
like crazy.
And I also think
that Barb and I together
will get it into retailers
across the country.
So, Barb, what do you
think of this?
Well, why don't we talk
behind their back?
We give them --
because the truth is,
I'd like to get a good deal.
Okay.
Do you mind stepping out
for a minute, ladies?
Go ahead.
I see this two ways.
Number one -- I see it
as a little bit of a challenge
for us
against our male sharks...
Oh, we are gonna succeed
just to show you guys.
I have zero interest in this.
...Because I would love
to show them how this
becomes a million-dollar
business immediately.
So, that's like me
saying to you, "why don't
you do technology deals?
You never do technology
deals. Why don't you do
technology deals?"
we do technology deals.
You're fools. Miss it.
CUBAN: I don't know.
Be careful what you offer.
I might come in,
just to prove a point.
Don't do that.
They were asking 20%.
Now, you and I both know
that we have to do a lot of
work to get it out there.
I'm not getting up for 10%
on this deal.
I'll tell you, I --
okay. What -- what would you
like to ask for?
CUBAN: I don't know.
Be careful what you offer.
All right, you can come
back in, ladies!
HERJAVEC:
I don't know.
GREINER: Okay, so,
here's our offer.
Our offer
is $75,000 for 40%.
What kind of greed
is this?
Barb and I together,
so you know we will help
get you into everywhere.
You know --
there's a very important piece,
though,
that she also wants
to mention.
Yes. A $100,000 credit line,
as well.
Over the -- over the cash,
because you're gonna need it.
Over it, to help fulfill
the purchase orders.
That's our offer.
Sold.
And we take it.
There!
We accept!
They like that. Mark, we didn't
hear you say anything.
CORCORAN: We should've asked
for more.
Okay.
These are the women
that can take us
where we need to go.
Yes!
There we go, Barb.
And we're on the ground,
girls.
Yeah, we will make you
so happy.
You're a loser. You're a loser.
You're a loser.
These are awesome.
I can't wait to try them on.
Yay!
I think they look awesome.
Oh, thank you so much!
I'm so excited!
I'm hot. She's hot.
She's hot.
She's hot. We're hot.
We're hot. We're hot.
Your head's gonna explode.
You're not. You're not.
[ laughs ]
You go, girl.
Kevin and I are gonna start
our own line -- tush push.
[ laughter ]
BICKLEY:
It feels so great
to be validated
by these women.
And our customers
have known what we have,
and now two expert,
genius businesswomen
recognized immediately
what Hold Your Haunches has.
GREER: It's just the answer
to all our prayers.
It's gonna be
a game-changer.